Welcome back to the lectures on
higher-order functions.
We just looked at the
mother of all higher-order functions
over lists: foldr.
And we will end this section
with a few other standard higher-order
functions that are available
in the Haskell library.
One of those functions is function
composition. And function composition is
another fundamental operation
in functional programming. Functional
programming is programming with
functions
and if we have functions, we want to
combine two functions into another
function.
Just like addition takes two numbers and
gives us a new number
we want to have a similar operator that
takes two functions
and combines them into a new function.
Here is the definition of that operator
and it is written as dot in Haskell.
So unlike
object-oriented programming, where dot
means invoking a method
in Haskell, dot means composing two
functions. So
in both cases the dot is used for the
most
fundamental operation on the objects
that the language supports. In an
object-oriented language
we have objects and we can call methods
on them. In Haskell
we have functions that we can compose.
And here is the type. Function
composition dot
takes a function from b to c. There is
the function from b to c.
Then it takes a function from a to b, and
it returns a function from
a to c. When you look at this
type, it can be a little bit confusing.
Because there is a b here as the output
and the b is here as the input.
It seems to be that things are in the wrong
order. But that has
everything to do with the fact that
function application associates. Here is
the definition
of composition. What we do is we
have two functions and then
we first apply g to x
and then we apply f to the result.
Let's now see
if those types make sense to us.
The type of f here
is a function from b to c. The type of
g is a function from a to b.
Then in that case x must be a value of
type a.
So if we apply g
to x, we are applying this function,
that takes an a into a b.
So the result of applying g to x is b.
And that fits into here and we get a c.
Let's look at the
return type here. We get a value of
type a
and we return a value of type c.
At first that type might look
a little bit confusing
but once we figure it out and we
use the fact that
function application here associates to
the right
everything falls into place.
And here is an example of using function
composition.
Suppose we want to define the function
odd, that
checks whether an integer is odd.
Odd is defined as not even.
Well, there we go. The definition, it says
first check whether it's even and then
invert the result. And this definition here
this is what people often call pointfree
style.
Because the other way we could write
odd would be: lambda x, even of x
not of that. But now we have a lambda and
parentheses, so that is a
little bit verbose.
A lot of functional programmers
prefer to use function
composition
to remove all the lambdas and the
parentheses. But I have to warn you.
And I'm guilty of this too.
When you just start using function
composition
you are trying to use it everywhere.
And it becomes a sport
to write things in pointfree style, write
them very compactly.
The price you pay is that it becomes very
hard to read. So now the people that
read your code
have to undo all this function composition
in order to understand what's going on.
And typically
when they understand what's going on, the
light bulb goes on, and they say
ah okay, but I think it is better to use
function composition sparingly
because you always have to write code
for others to read.
You don't write code to look
cool yourself and say: oh look, I can do
this pointfree style.
Plus there are automatic programs
that make things pointfree for you, so
you are not as cool as you think.
So use function composition
sparingly
and don't go bananas with function
composition.
Okay.
Here are a couple of other functions
that are in the standard library,
higher-order functions.
Most of them are defined
using foldr or using
comprehensions. These are all
interchangeable.
I prefer using foldr.
Some people prefer
list comprehensions. The reason I
prefer foldr, is that
foldr, this concept of folding over
a data type, works for any recursive data
type
whereas list comprehensions only work
for lists.
We can use general comprehensions, but
it gets all a little bit tedious.
So at some point it's just easier to
define a fold function and then define
other functions on top of that.
But let's just look at this one here.
All is defined
as map
p of x to the list xs
and then check whether every one of
those is true.
A nicer definition of this would be
map of p compose and. Any
is the same thing. We map p
over the list xs and then we call
or. So for example if we want to check
that
this string here "abc def"
contains a space, we can call any isSpace
function from character to Bool and this
will return True.
Here is another interesting function:
takeWhile. TakeWhile takes a predicate
and unlike filter, which goes through the
whole list and throws away all the
elements
for which the predicate does not hold,
takeWhile
is like a while loop, so it uses
this predicate
and chops off elements from this list
and returning them
until this predicate is False. So let's
look at the definition.
If the list is empty, what can we do?
We can only return the empty list.
In case we have a non-empty list
it looks like this: x:xs
and now we have two cases. Either
p of x does not hold, in that case we
terminate the recursion by
returning the empty list
and if p of x is True...
There is a trapdoor here in the studio!
TakeWhile not fall through the
hole... if p of x is True
then we cons x onto the recursive call
of takeWhile of p of x. So for example
we have a string and we can take
characters from the string as long
as they are
letters, by doing takeWhile isAlpha
and then
it will take abc. And since the space
is not
an alphanumeric character it will
terminate
right there. Dually to takeWhile
we have the function dropWhile, that
removes all the elements
while a predicate holds. So takeWhile
keeps all the elements until the
predicate is False
dropWhile drops the elements
until the predicate turns False.
So you see here that in this case it
drops the value
and instead of returning the empty list
there, it just
puts the value on top of the rest.
Good! Happy hacking
and make sure you do the exercises,
because
all the higher-order functions that we have
seen here, like takeWhile, dropWhile, map
filter
you will have to implement them in
terms of foldr.
So please make these exercises
and if you are not using Haskell, say
you are using Scala or Java
you can do the same thing. These
languages typically
also have foldr. Maybe it's not
called foldr.
Sometimes it is called foldRight or
sometimes it is just called fold
but this idea of having a higher-order
function
that captures the essence of recursing
over a list
is available in any library
that supports lists.
And for example in C# it is not even
called foldr.
It is called aggregate.
That comes from SQL, where you are
aggregating over a list.
So don't be fooled by the name, the
idea is what matters.
Thank you so much and see you next week.